m
[Musique]
depuis que je le connais il n'a jamais
eu qu'un seul but
[Musique]
exterminer la moitié de l'univers
s'il s'empare de toutes les pierres
d'infinité il pourra le faire d'un
simple claquement de doigts comme ça
rappelez moi comment il s'appelle thanos
[Musique]
nous avons un avantage
il va venir nous
nous avons ce que veux tu annonces et
nous l'utiliserons
[Musique]
bon parlons un peu de votre plan je le
trouve excellent à ceci près qu'il est
nul
alors laissez-moi faire le plan est
comme ça il sera beaucoup mieux
la fin est proche
quand j'en aurai terminé
[Musique]
la moitié de l'humanité aura la vie
sauve
c'est un parfait équilibre
comme toute chose devrait l'être
souhaitons que le monde se souvienne de
vaud
[Musique]
au fait je m'appelle peter docteur
strange au concert de nos pseudos nîmes
dans ce cas je suis spider man